[Musik]
ein wunderschöner mittag erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
fällt um meine lieben freunde ich nehme
erst mal ganz kurzem ein schild das sind
einmal soviel sicht weg unten links
allerdings seht ihr jetzt bereits den
titel eingeblendet vorher werk heute
geht es ab ich hoffe wir kriegen das hin
was ich mir vorgenommen habe denn ich
habe in der letzten episode also folge
96 gesagt er verbräuche ganz kurz im
vorstand ab warum erfahrt ihr gleich ich
habe euch auf jeden fall in der letzten
episode gesagt mensch leute wenn ihr
irgendwelche ideen habt was ich noch
machen soll in dem projekt das mit luca
dann sagt mir etikett für diese episode
denn da müssen wir jetzt wirklich ein
bisschen durchziehen weil die nächsten
drei episoden also folge 98/99 in folge
100 die sind alle ziemlich krass
durchgetaktet nur heute haben wir noch
so ein bisschen in eigener hand da ich
habe generell in eigener hand wie ich
das ganze projekt hier an gehe aber
heute ist das letzte mal wo wir so ein
bisschen andere sache machen können
jetzt nichts mit dem ende des korrekt zu
tun haben weil der hand oder andere wird
wahrscheinlich erinnern folge 98 die
jetzt die tage kommen wird die komplette
vorbereitung für das ändern wir werden
ganz viele sachen verzaubern wir wehren
uns ganz viele sachen kräften wir werden
eine menge menge fit machen der nicht so
krass unterhaltsam wird aber einfach
eine produktive folge wird das 1099 wird
das beste auf seinen das projekt eine
halbe stunde lang die besten szenen der
kompletten ersten staffel mit luca
werden wir uns angucken da werden wir
eine leinwand bauen auf der wir das
gucken können hab ich auch keine
kommentare geschrieben bekommen also
danke dir da auf jeden fall für den tipp
beziehungsweise zu den vorschlag das mit
folgen 99 sein formel 100 dann
selbstverständlich das ende wir gehen in
das ende die nehmen es mit dem ende traf
und hoffentlich schaffen wir es
allerdings wie bereits gesagt heute
erstmal so die letzte richtige folge ich
habe mir eine menge ist dafür die
kommentare geschrieben eine menge tipps
vorschläge und auch ein paar
erinnerungen kamen noch rein wie
beispielsweise luca da gibt es auch
schon fehlerfall buch vier verzauberung
also ein ziemlich gutes verzauberung
buch was sich wohl in der kiste habe
liegen lassen bei ihnen im zombies
bonner und da wird dann auch geschrieben
jahres waren der und der folge ich hab
mir die ganze folge noch mal angeguckt
die geringe halbe stunde und ich habe
nirgendwo dieses buch entdeckt ich habe
mir extra die time labs in 0,25 facher
geschwindigkeit angeguckt als ich saß
gerade 34 schon gefragt wo ist dieses
buch und hab es nicht gefunden also
danke dir für deinen kommentar
vielleicht etwas gesehen oder was ich
nicht gesehen habe was ich irgendwie
übersehen haben oder so allerdings haben
wir in unserer christoph fehlerfall
bücher zwar nur feder fall zwei wir
werden die dann einfach nehmen für die
verzauberung folge 98 dann allerdings
wohl mit eine menge sachen die
kommentare geschrieben unter anderem
auch das hier du kannst deinen braus
stand und fahrt zurück zum wasser dorf
ihr seht das wasser doch wie vorne schon
eingeblendet dass mit dem bau staaten
hat nämlich dahingehend etwas damit zu
tun dass unser wille job wohl dann
endlich neue angebote bekommt und wir
uns zum glück dann hoffentlich doch noch
die ein oder andere ende perle vertreten
können mit dem dude dass wir auf jeden
fall von essentieller notwendigkeit für
das ende und wird uns auf jeden fall
wird mir zumindest ein besseres gefühl
geben wenn das ende zu gehen weil habe
ich euch auch schon von 1 verfolgen
gesagt man hat immer von dem ende
drachen hoch geschleudert wird und es
sein könnte dass ich sehr sehr hoch
geschleudert werden und dementsprechend
durch den fall schaden sterbe deswegen
benötigen wir auf jeden fall feder fall
also hier ist ein brauch stand da kann
er hin und jetzt hat er hat er hat neue
angebote sehr gut wir können uns so
viele länder perlen wie geht und zwar
elf stück jetzt haben wir nur noch 32
märkte wir können uns natürlich mit
[Musik]
mache ich jetzt auch wir hier unten
jetzt meine inventar eingeblendet seht
haben wir dem aufstieg wieder
mitgenommen wir haben nur noch drei
smaragde und elf ender perlen allerdings
deswegen
müssen wir jetzt ein bisschen gucken wie
wir das machen mit dem handy ich weiß
nicht ob ich noch irgendwie ein bisschen
trading muss weil das ist jetzt nicht
mehr möglich ich habe einen preis markt
kann allerdings natürlich mit den
dorfbewohnern auf meiner innen sind auch
noch ein bisschen hole er tauschen dann
kriege ich noch mal ein bisschen
smaragde blabla und nicht mal die
wichtigsten sachen also zum beispiel
eine axt oder so das haben wir auch
schon dass wir beispielsweise auch und
in die kommentare geschrieben luca
machten die aktien der java version also
die die ich spiele ist eine direkt
deutlich stärker als ein diamant schwert
deswegen werde ich auf jeden fall meine
diamant axt auch in der nächsten folge
verzaubern und damit haben jetzt sogar
tatsächlich schon das mit dem geistig
namen gemacht wir haben die direkt die
musste ich mir nicht schafften die habe
ich nämlich schon das fehlerfall bohol
ich nicht und dann komme ich jetzt auch
schon zum vierten kommentar der wir uns
in die kommentare geschrieben wurden
zwei lukat bitte bitte bitte macht doch
mal ein feuerwerk und das seht ihr schon
in dem titel eingeblendet ich hoffe dass
wir das heute hinkriegen ich möchte mich
so ein kleines feuerwerk machen ich habe
eine menge schwarzpulver noch bei mir in
den kisten weil wir halt eine menge
keeper und läutet freibergs hier
genau das ist der kripo sein wenn die
kommen ich hab ne menge creeper getötet
in dem projekt mannschaft mit lukas habe
anderthalb stacks schwarzpulver oder
irgendwie so und das geile ist
was soll das jetzt so steigt der idiotie
plötzlich auf seinem boot aus alter
komplett sie ist weil hier ein ja wir
fahren jetzt schnurstracks zurück in der
hinteren insel die sache ist dass ich
mir gedacht habe mensch wenn wir in der
[Musik]
vorletzten
mit meinem deutsche sorry neben bach
runter gegangen wenn wir uns in der
übernächsten folge dieses best of
angucken macht vielleicht sinn das ganze
auf einer leinwand zu machen ich hätte
sich noch ein extra riesiges kino bauen
wie schön dieser leuchtturm ist und ich
werde so eine kleine leinwand bauen wo
wir uns das ganz entspannt angucken
können das werde ich auf jeden fall auch
noch gleich machen und dann möchte ich
auch schon das feuerwerk so ein bisschen
testen denn dann ich möchte dass das so
dass wir dann so das best-of gucken und
dann kann man sie das feuerwerk in den
himmel schleudert ich weiß gar nicht für
feuerwerk für uns machen können ob das
überhaupt ausreichen wird das schauen
wir uns gleich auf jeden fall mal an
allerdings merkte ich schon ich bin
irgendwie happy aber irgendwie auch dich
das fühlt sich für mich gerade an wie
sonnenurlaub der jetzt nach manjipoor
boost den urlaub zwei wochen irgendwie
heiße ich nicht italien oder spanien
oder keine ahnung warum habe ich
überhaupt noch brot stehen und dann
denkt man sich so ok war jetzt cool die
zwei wochen aber ich freue mich auch auf
zu hause und so geht es mir irgendwie
gerade so ein bisschen es war cool die
letzten gut jetzt nicht zwei wochen
sondern eher halbes jahr geht ja dieses
projekt schon allerdings
ist es auch irgendwie so ein bisschen
traurig was auch schön freut sich gegen
visum
[Musik]
warum
man mal so oder so kommen das ist ach
das ist der raum den ich nicht so
richtig zu gebaut habe ich idiot gut
dann nehme ich das mal ganz kurz eben
meine buchstein und kann hier so ein
bisschen das ganze zu bauen das ist ja
hier vorn ist ja unser karotten fall
müssen wir auch noch mal eben ganz kurz
gucken ob da alles läuft die decke rot
gefahren denn das benötigen wir bis zum
ende die karotten benötigen ja definitiv
auch fürs ende weil uns damit goldene
karotten machen die am besten nahrung
geben hier ist allerdings gar nichts
erwachsen
was sollen die scheiße jetzt wir gehen
hier allerdings mal wieder direkt hoch
und nähmen unser verrottetes fleisch und
können dass er mal ganz kurz eben balu
und valencia gegeben haben die beiden
auch mal wieder geführt hatte und jetzt
werde ich erst mal ganz kurz den brauch
schon wieder noch da oben bringen bevor
ich es vergesse und hier irgendwie euch
dann nachher die welt gäbe das ist
natürlich auch ein großer bestandteil
von folge 100 dann müsst ihr alle
einschalten dann gibt sie den download
und den zieht dann könnt ihr euch das
ganze mal selber angucken die ganze welt
damit nicht irgendwas hier noch rom
steht daneben welchen orten wo es nicht
sein soll wir werden außerdem nicht
schlafen gehen denn es ist ja immer noch
eine gewisse chance vorhanden dass wir
phantome bekommen auf unsere insel ich
werde mir jetzt allerdings erstmal
feuerwerks raketen bauen koop das gibt
das geht ja vertrag
wir können es ja voll viele machen
ich glaube ein steak reicht oder naja er
was man auch geschrieben wurde war luca
du kannst die tnt einfach mal machen ich
habe aber keinen sand doch aber ich habe
auch ein bisschen sand dafür kann ich
auch meinen schießpulver so ein bisschen
verwenden da kann ich das ganze nämlich
einfach so an
da kann ich das ganze nicht einfach so
anordnen und kann mir eine menge tnt
machen und das ist geil mit dem tmt ist
halt dass ich das auch für das ende ganz
gut gebrauchen kann weil ich dann dort
jetzt keinen sand meer
ich habe 16 tnt ich glaub ich hab sogar
noch ich habe sogar 30 tnt das schreibe
ich nicht einmal ganz kurz auf meine
liste auf tnt so zeigt das dass das
läuft ich habe mir gedacht dass wir das
tnt ganz gut verwenden keine kommentare
geschrieben weil ich damit dann auch
wenn der ändert rache zu seiner station
zurück fliegt das werden wir alles in
folge 100 sehen damit kann ich dann auch
das tnt dahinter
ich wollte sagen das ist ja eh alles aus
barock und dann kann nicht da ein
bisschen den ender drachen auf damit
angreifen perfekt ich finde sich doch
irgendwie hochgeklettert damit auf
einmal schild die hier auf dem dach und
von der seite auch noch
perfekt dümmste spinne der welt einfach
ich habe mir jetzt diese 63
feuerwerksraketen gemacht und ich weiß
im titel steht feuerwerk und da denkt
man vielleicht wog am 18 großes
feuerwerk nee ich hab so was in
minecraft endlich ist auch noch nie so
richtig gemacht deswegen will ich es
heute nur einmal ganz kurz testen und
dementsprechend die ganzen restlichen
feuerwerkskörper also die 62 die wir da
noch übrig haben werden in der folge
verballern wo dann das beste auch
wirklich stattfindet deswegen fangen
jetzt erst mal hier zu unserer insel ich
weiß ich hab so ein feuerwerkskörper
wenn ich den auf meiner insel zünder und
er irgendwie einen baum fliegt das dann
alles anfing zu brennen bei meinem glück
hat dass er mal ab und zu passieren
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht habe ich
mal wieder hier zu unserer kleinen test
abbau insel ich glaube man kann einfach
mit dem feuerwerkskörper rechts auf dem
boden machen
eine stunde später
das ist jetzt nicht war oder
ich brauche feuerwerks stern also ich
habe keine ahnung was die scheiße jetzt
soll und ob meine ganzen
feuerwerksraketen nicht mehr gemacht
habe schlussendlich jetzt für die katz
sind allerdings glaube ich dass ich mir
wirklich irgendwie das falsche crafted
habe weil hier gerade im minecraft
fandom wikipedia was mir jedes mal bei
jeder vw leitet steht dass wenn ich
effekte auf meiner feuerwerksrakete
haben möchte dass sich dann das ganze
mit feuerwerk sterne noch machen muss
und die muss sich teilweise mit
diamanten dann noch irgendwie
verzauberten watts
bin ich reich nehmen jetzt einfach mal
grünen farbstoff frauen hier ein
schwarzpulver in grünen farbstoff und ne
da da ging es aber gerade schon guck mal
hier feuerwerk sternenexplosionen grün
ok jetzt nehme ich meine rakete und
macht den feuerwerk sternexplosionen gut
geht nicht
gibt's nicht das geht nur so
nicht irgendwie oder
in denen die jetzt alle umsonst waren
diese 61 raketen
wenn die alle umsonst wenn das jetzt
hier mit funktioniert dann kriegt dann
jetzt aber holland in not
[Musik]
also dass
mit luca intouch ich
haue dieses ding nach oben wir haben ein
feuerwerk direkt neben dem phantom ich
guck runter in kryta der explodiert und
nicht direkt von skelett dort
am 1
was passiert wenn ich hier drin eine
sünde oh wow
es wird irgendwie gefühl schon so ein
bisschen hell draußen deswegen müssen
wir uns jetzt ein bisschen beeilen und
mal schauen wie wir das jetzt mit dem
phantom machen wir haben hier vorne erst
mal noch ein skelett das hat einfach
goldene busan ok crazy wir müssen es mit
dem phantom aufnehmen wir haben noch ein
skelett super perfektes heimweg hier
wo bist du
von allen seiten
sagt von der seite auch noch ja kaum
noch her sagt auf dem grat ehren loser
schmutz bürger so ganz schnell zum ofen
kartoffel rein wir müssen uns irgendwie
mit diesem ding da oben aufnehmen weil
wir das brauchen für den sanften fall
ich weiß nicht genau wie wir das kriegen
können und ich weiß auch nicht wo das
phantom
ist
ach
guck mal
die hat den knuffig
der ist echt süß finde ich
ihn könnte man sich als haustier
besorgen komm mal her ich lag die mein
mann
hat mir gar kein schaden gemacht es ist
ein idiot
das ist ja voll das opfer war mit den
leben lassen
einfach tot
und ich hab nichts holen leute treiben
hier die
auch ihr mann meister hier unten wird
auf jeden fall eine menge in die luft
gesprengt das können wir aber auf jeden
fall gleich nochmal alles wieder
aufbauen ich sprint hier mal so ein
bisschen über meine dächer und schob das
phantom eventuell hier irgendwo was hat
fallen lassen und vielleicht
ja auch nichts vor sie das schön aus
ich fühle mich so wie in der großstadt
um uns so auf dem dach schild und dann
so die sonne aufgeht und man das über
den dächern der stadt sieht
nur dass das bei mir halt keine stadt
sondern irgendwie mehr ist allerdings
habe ich mir noch mal ganz kurz anrufen
kartoffel ohne ohren und dann jetzt auch
mal ganz kurz eben eine provisorische
leiter hier leute 2 wächst hier
[Musik]
all ihre liebe
allemal
[Musik]
paco und läutet fand ich ja
scheiße alter sein das waren sie denn
hier acht mal hier kann der mini bzw
ihr kriegt den easy besiegt
ja das ist halt das problem daran wenn
man nicht so richtig schlafen geht weil
ich will dass diese blöden
teile dass frauen diese blöden
symptome die sache ist nur ich weiß auch
gar nicht ob die die greift mich nicht
anwalt haben wir wieder ein krieg hier
vorne werde ich wieder geschlagen ich
will einfach nur ein sonnen phantom
töten okay ich habe ein phantom getötet
habe ich will dass er dieses phantom
fell oder wie das heißt es sein dass
dropped und ich weiß nicht warum weil
eigentlich alle mops truppen doch was
wenn man die besiegten creeper drop doch
immer schwarz vor risiken
[Musik]
wo kann das denn jetzt plötzlich ja
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht warum
mir das hier wieder passieren konnte es
war doch alles eigentlich gut getimt
getaktet es hat alles gut funktioniert
aber gut hier vorne noch was hin hier
kommt dann der weg gehen hier auch da
muss das gras einfach ein bisschen
weiter wachsen hierfür brauchen wir eben
zwei bruchstein stufen nochmal so dass
das ganze dann so aussieht ich glaube
dass da auch in etwa so aus wir können
noch mal eben ganz kurz die schaufel
nehmen und das hier so ein bisschen
china machen dann wollen wir das nehme
ich hier so ab dass wir hier so ein
bisschen unserem kleineren übergang
haben also hier auch nochmal kurz gerne
rein und jetzt ganz schnell noch mal
eben rüber he was hier vorne jetzt
passiert ist ich weiß nicht woher kam
die müssen wir noch holz hinsetzen
gleich und hier vorne war dann glaube
ich hier war irgendwie sonnenweg drum
rum sind wir sind war der held der war
sogar freigelassen glaube ich hier oder
ich weiß es nicht wollen jetzt einfach
mal so dann ging es ja hier auf jeden
fall irgendwie so runter dann können wir
hier noch ein bisschen bruchstein
verwenden dass wir irgendwas ihr dass
sie überhaupt noch in diesem projekt
allerdings voll wir haben der insel
reparatur folge ich ja jetzt auch schon
wieder nicht was soll denn die kacke
jetzt schon ja wir haben das alles so
gut gemeistert aber ich glaube hier
nicht bei ihnen ja auch der weg lang rum
man muss sich jetzt nur noch eben hier
vorne der baumax auch halb weg was
sollen das war so schön mit dem
durchgang aber gut müssen wir jetzt
leider mit leben wie hole ich noch mal
eben kurz ist das eine ja das ist so
dass ich das auch noch mal eben kurz
aufbauen kann und dann meine lieben
freunde würde ich an der stelle die
heutige episode minecraft mit luca
darauf beende ich dachte die tür ist ja
auch herausgerissen worden ich nehme mal
eben kurz hier ein bisschen dass es
entrindet habe ich nicht noch normales
eichenholz oder bin ich einfach blind
ich hab kein holz mehr absetzte vorne
ist allerdings einfach wieder neuen
setzlingen so dass da hoffentlich ein
relativ ähnlicher baum wächst und wir
hier vorne jetzt unser eichenholz nehmen
können und dass hier ganz entspannt aber
dazwischen setzen können als wenn nie
was passiert den weg hier würde ich gern
jetzt direkt schon weiter ziehen
allerdings muss das gras hat erstmal ein
bisschen weiter wachsen der weg geht er
dann hier vorne so ein bisschen rum es
war halt sehr schön hier mit dem
durchgang mit dem eichenlaub beziehung
das kann ja
was soll der geiz ich habe jetzt leider
nur zwölf akazien laub allerdings ist es
ja zumindest etwas damit dass hier
zumindest ein bisschen vorziehen haben
wir dann den weg darunter her und ich
glaube dass hier war sogar so ein
bisschen höher gezogen noch oder habe
ich bin mir auch grad gar nicht mal so
richtig sicher ich glaube allerdings
dass das so ein bisschen so war dass man
hier so hergeben konnte hier vielleicht
auch noch so das hat sich also ein
bisschen wie so ein tunnel angefühlt als
man immer durch gelaufen ist ich weiß es
nicht mehr genau könnt ihr mir gerne in
die kommentare schreiben was ich hier
eventuell falsch gemacht habe oder
falsch zu gebaut habe oder neu gebaut
habe vielleicht saß aber auch so aus wie
wenn ihr dann verdammt ja auf jeden fall
so hier bin ich lange laufen dann war
das vielleicht hier nochmal ein hör-
oder irgendwie so ich weiß es nicht mehr
ich lasse es einfach so
müssen wir damit leben meine liebe
freunde wir würden an der stelle
allerdings die heutige episode
mannschaft mit dugard auf werden bzw ich
würde heute gab die sodann der stelle
ist auch beenden wenn es euch gefallen
hat dann das kann einen daumen hoch
unter dem video hier da abonniert main
kanal und klickt auf die glocke wenn ihr
die nächsten episoden minecraft nicht
verpassen wollte das wird sehr krass in
der nächsten episode bauen wir dann die
laien waren was ich heute nicht
geschafft habe wir bauen den man dann
einfach einer nächsten episode machen
dann unsere ganzen stadt verzaubern und
anzünder zeugs und blase dass wir dann
fertig sind für die letzte episode folge
100 wo wir uns das ende besuchen und da
hoffentlich den drachen besiegen während
in folge 90 mal ein kleines beste auto
aber neben den kanal klickt auf die
glocke wir sehen uns dann wieder
[Musik]